[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today John in
quotes that's not his real name in other
words from Louisville Kentucky not his
real place in quotes big secret call
coming in so John what's your question
yes sir um well about about two years
ago I I won one of those multi-state
lottery drawings with a group of
co-workers and uh I haven't told and one
uh besides my wife and besides one
sibling uh no one knows and my my
question for you um after taxes it was
about $22
million holy crap wow holy crap is
the century yeah how old are you it was
it was a lot uh I'm I'm edging up on uh
about 50 years old okay okay and so you
haven't told anyone and I've got some
guesses but uh why
uh well the first thing I did when when
I found out that I won was was research
and it said you know that you read all
those one in five people lose their uh
lottery winnings or go bankrupt within
10 years and one of the things they all
said was you tell too many people and
you get too many people at your door
asking for this that and the other thing
asking for handouts and expecting you to
pay for everything so my wife and I made
a conscious decision just to kind of
keep it under wraps and it's kind of we
we've kept keeping it under wraps um we
haven't even told our two teenage
children MH and now I know that sounds
strange um but we just don't want them
to grow up uh to be waiters you know
waiting for us to die so they can get
our
money you
know that's fantastic man yeah I love it
dad's been eating little rat poison
lately I probably hey I honestly uh I
I'll spend the rest of the day imagining
I'm you because this sounds just like a
fun thing to think about um I don't
think I would tell my teenage kids
either no I'm okay with that no they're
I I I want them to go figure out what
they want to do in life and get get
going and then I'll and then I'll let
them know I'm not I'm not going to keep
it from them forever but like you know
our parents and stuff we haven't told
any of them um we had we had another
incident about a month after we won the
lottery um incident I I don't want to
call it my wife's great uncle passed
away
shortly thereafter and he didn't have
any kids and he was never married and he
left most of his inheritance to my wife
and her siblings so we've been able to
use that as like our cover story for
when we help people like I bought my mom
a roof I know really really nice of me
yeah but how you know when she says how
can you afford this I just say oh it's
great Uncle Bob's money mom he want he
wanted us to do this you know Uncle
Bob's money at least two x now that's
great yeah and you can get you can get
have you got a decent
car I you're going to love me Dave uh my
house was paid off before I won this my
wife and I really have no desire to move
good uh we had just paid cash for two
Toyotas before we uh before we won this
and we still have them we're not looking
to upgrade to anything because they're
perfectly fine cars so okay we uh we we
are you still working are you still
working I am still I am still working is
that ridiculous no it's not no actually
that's why I'm there because I kind of
like my job good for you I think you
should keep working yeah it's going to
make you a better employee because when
have you gotten some great investment
advice I have yes I have I have a team
as you can imagine okay with this you
need a you need a team yeah not a huge
team it's just it's a group and they're
they're they're doing well so far doing
good job good okay I like everything
you're doing um and it's not it's not
anyone else's
business right that's what I hope and um
I don't think you're being like uh
hermit in a cave weird uni weird or
something like that I think you're just
being wise because what you've what
you've discerned is that some of the
people in your life could not
handle the
equation correct that is an a Very uh
good assumption on your part yeah and
and so you're doing them a favor by not
putting the strain on them including
teenagers so the only thing I can get
close to is is that um by the time my
kids were teenagers we had begun
building substantial
wealth we had recovered from the
bankruptcy Rachel was born so by the
time Rachel's 16 it's you know 17 years
since the bankruptcy and we had you know
I was a multi-millionaire again okay we
could buy whatever car we wanted to buy
we could go on whatever vacation we
wanted to go on and it wouldn't affect
us we had good money okay uh but the
kids had no idea and our kids had a
double problem one is their dads in the
Spotlight and everybody knows us right
because we're known in the community um
and talks about money no du a and if
they had that and they knew that we had
millions of dollars as a teenager I
don't think they could have processed it
so they did not know they knew we were
okay with money they knew we live the
principles that we teach and we made
them live the principles that we teach
but they did not know X number of
dollars was the net worth right I only
disclosed that to them after they
graduated from college and I involved
their spouses because by that time two
of them were married and so I sat down
with three of my kids and two spouses
five of them and we started unpacking
what our estate plan looks like because
they're adults at that point and I told
them up front I said listen here's the
deal we don't own anything at our house
we're people of Faith so God owns a
bunch of stuff he's ask has us to manage
more than you know and you're getting
ready to know now and you get to decide
how you're going to react to that are
you going to react and continue to be
productive and generous people or are
you going to be in using your words and
I'll never forget it a waiter right uh
because if you're a waiter you're not
going to get access to any of this we're
going to take it away from you because
God wants you to be productive he wants
you to be whole he wants you to be
excellent in the marketplace and he
doesn't want this to destroy you he
wants you to have the opportunity to
serve a lot of people with this wealth
including my grandkids to come and so as
for me in my house we serve the Lord and
it's not our money it's his we're
managing it for him and someday you will
take over the management but you will
not become the owner if you think you're
the owner you won't get to take over the
management and we that's how I unpacked
it and then when I unpacked it I was
really pleased that they weren't Freaks
and they've continued to live really
good adult lives and it's it's not not
ruined them that their dad has you know
Dad and Mom have a bunch of money that
they manage you know so uh all that so I
think you could start to build some
lessons into your teenagers now so that
in five years when you have that
conversation they're ready to shoulder
the weight of it what do you think John
all right yeah I think you can live by
example and I think you have a pretty
remarkable opportunity
to take your kids out when you are
having taking them out to dinner and
noticing a waiter that's struggling and
call the waiter over and be really kind
and then show your kids let's leave a
huge tip you want to do that and it
might be a hundred bucks which is
nothing of of what you got in the bank
but it's it's going to be a million
dollars to a teenager right and you can
slowly plant the seeds of this is what
generosity looks like and when they it's
it's kind of like those movies you get
to the end and it like the six sense
right and it goes and you realize oh no
I missed the whole story and now I have
the whole story one day when you sit
down and say hey I'm uh you know that
school that I paid for and you know you
and your wife are about to buy a
house I'm going to pay for your mortgage
and here's actually what we're sitting
on and here's I I like who I'm honored
by who you have become they're going to
go oh man I picked up all these lessons
from my mom and my dad they're also
going to learn that money isn't what
makes isn't your identity your
identities in being a great dad it's a
guy who still got up and went to work
it's a guy who still kept the same
Toyota that he'd already paid with cash
before like you're doing everything so
right so healthy it's amazing healthy
yeah man good for you if you if you were
hiding this cuz you were freaking and
you were weird I would call I would I
call you out on it you're wise you're
wise I think in this case you're
wise my my sister called me the other
day and said what was your big splurge
and my answer was patio furniture I'm
not a big flashy guy I I I don't well I
I I think you need to increase gradually
the enjoyment of this money
not to not not in the name of the secret
not in the name of exposing the secret
but you need to increase the enjoyment
and you need to increase your generosity
Factor systematically you need to say
all right this year we're going to spend
$400,000 on this of that create some
neat memories with your kids yeah do do
some things intentionally with this
without just kind of roll rolling up an
extra million bucks into the budget this
year you don't have to do that although
you've got it but um yeah wow
congratulations brother it's a very good
healthy view this is the Ramsey Show